of exponential growth well it's this
equation right here it's y equals a
times e raised to the BX power so a is
the initial quantity e is the natural
base e 2.71 and let's look at an example
we'll show you how to work with this
formula so the number of insects is
increasing according to the law of
exponential growth okay after four days
there are 200 insects and after six days
there are 800 insects
how many insects will there be after ten
days okay so assuming that it's
following this you know law of
exponential growth so what they're
giving us here are basically a couple of
coordinates are saying after four days
there are 200 insects and after six days
there are 800 insects and we're trying
to figure out how many there's going to
be after 10 days right so let's go ahead
and solve for a and B okay these are our
unknowns whenever you have two variables
you need two equations to solve for them
right so we're going to put 200 in for y
okay equals a times e to the B times 4
right that's our first equation there
second equation we've got 800 equals a
times e to the B times 6 right so we're
going to do here is we're going to solve
for a and we're going to substitute it
into the second equation so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to divide by e
to the 4 B so we've got 200 over e to
the 4 B equals a we're going to take
that quantity from this first equation
and we're going to put it in for a in
the second equation so that's just a
substitution right so we have 800 equals
200 over e to the 4 B times e to the 6 B
right and remember anything divided by 1
is itself but when you're dividing what
do you do to the exponents if you have
the same base you subtract right so 6 B
minus 4 B is just going to give us 2 B
so we have 800 equals 200 times e to the
2 B right 6 B minus 4 B 2 B we're going
to divide both sides by 200 so if we do
that we get 4 equals e to the 2 B now
because our variables in the exponent
position we're gonna have to take the
log of both sides in this case the
natural log since it's
see here natural log of both sides these
are inverses of one other they cancel
one another out we get to be equals
natural log of four and if we divide
both sides by two we get B equals
natural log of four divided by two so
we'll just get a decimal approximation
for this one just so I can show you this
is a natural log of four divided by two
it's a point six nine three okay so we
know that B equals 0.693
that B value back in here we can solve
for a so let's go to the calculator
let's do that again
so we've got 200 divided by each of the
four times 0.693 okay so let's see what
that comes out to twelve point five okay
so our a value is twelve point five so
if we put all this back together into
our equation you can see we have y
equals twelve point five e to the point
six nine three X so that's our
exponential growth model but now what
we're trying to figure out is how many
insects will be after ten days so we're
going to put ten in place of X here and
then simplify so let's go ahead and do
that real quick we've got twelve point
five okay let's see here let's see do
that again
twelve point five 0.693 times ten okay
12700 eighty-one approximately so twelve
thousand seven hundred eighty-one
insects and that's it so there you go so
that's the exponential growth model y
equals a times e to the BX and again you
have two variables a and B so you need
two equations so that you can solve that
system so I hope this video helped you
understand how to work with us better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on Mars math tutoring
YouTube channel and I look forward to
seeing in the future videos I'll talk to
you soon